Heart Of Steel v-44m take 11 marker
excellent work buddy thank you yeah
that's good love it all right hey I'm a
big fan I'm excited you ready here we go
okay
[Music]
[Music]
hey I'm Joel
I've been a professional digital double
for 20 years now
when there's a stunt in a movie like
like the best stun in the movie you you
think that's the stunt guys no no that's
us the guys they bring in when the stunt
guys can't do it we're doing the
craziest things you see an explosion
that the person needs to be in a fire
that engulfs the person a shark attack
some normal guy
he'd be done but us Digis like that
that's what US Digis do we are
everywhere these days and the sad thing
is
you probably never heard of us
I mean ever since I was a kid I knew I
was different one day I'm in this tree
house right suddenly my leg gets caught
in the rung of the ladder I Flip Flip
seven eight nine times hit a tree branch
she bounces me up I go flying through
the Second Story window down the stairs
hit my head on the banister every rail
bam on the bottom I'm laying there for
something like 10 minutes and my mom
comes in the room she thought her son
died she's like my son just died no you
know that moment but uh nope I wasn't
dead in fact I think I was living for
the first time from there I was going
ham every day I was doing a new stunt
knew this knew that I was breaking
windows I broke more windows that summer
than most people breaking their lives
film and Mom get this freaking flying
off a cliff mom get this get hit by a
car third period in between classes I
just jumped straight down that stairwell
people lost their minds they're like
Joel is doing this later that day I was
sitting at the cool kids table and they
were all stabbing me with forks I was
just doing this I didn't know there was
a professional outlet for this but then
one day lawnmower man comes out and I'm
like
that's me that's me on camera
and everything changed
I knew I had to be in movies so the next
day I was divided onto like 100 floppy
disks shipped to Hollywood and I started
doing my magic baby spawn you remember
the hell scene all those demons I was
deeming 332. from there it was a
Snowball Effect it was the 90s it was
boomy like you get a did you double in a
movie in the 90s that movie is going to
be a success stuntmen yesterday's news
no one was doing what digi's can do the
propeller guy in Titanic that propeller
scene I think they ran it like 10 000
times sometimes I spun so fast that I
actually took off my agent's phone is
ringing out the hook hello hello hello I
I don't want to do my own horn I had a
little thing with PS1 Laura Croft
yeah I mean those those triangles man
those triangles one day I get the call
the call to end all calls they're
filming some movie with The Rock about a
mummy and like what do you want me to do
he says we need you to be the rock I
mean this was gonna be huge for Digis
everywhere right like I'm gonna be on
camera I'm gonna be up close I'm gonna
be an actor I get on set I'm doing
Dwayne I'm doing it all people love it
we think that went great that went great
the movie comes out
suddenly Everyone's a Critic first time
in history too much CGI too much I hear
words like disgusting
disturbing uncanny
we flew too close to the lens that day
if I could go back I'd maybe do a little
less scorpion a little more King
hello oh
hey come on in come on in welcome to my
humble abode uh I it's a little less
than what I'm used to uh well used to a
long time ago it's a one bedroom hey
come with me I want to see if my
roommate's home
oh
she's cool two bathrooms not bad not bad
and uh rent controlled rent controlled
oh yeah
you see those those are all bills they
date back to 2007 when I got my normal
smooth out just to keep up with the
industry
barely keeping up with interest at this
point it could always be worse though
like
see this guy
Barry Barry absolute legend in the
industry and now look at this sketchfab
Barry
and he's free
people don't even have to pay to use you
man
I mean yeah I missed the old days the
the industry changed like
they say CGI is ruining movies but maybe
it's the way we're making movies that's
ruining CGI
I mean we used to have value we used to
be Legends Marvel Marvel's the worst
Civil War I was playing Black Panther
you probably saw it you know the stunt
guy did most of that and it was fine so
I come in I match the movements yeah I'm
doing this I'm doing that you know how
tiring it is to match a guy one for one
so you've worked with gee to self agree
yeah yeah I worked with him did he ever
talk to me did he ever extend a help in
hand
no show me a stunt man who can do this
I'll wait
they're starting to get the credit
they're there for a couple hours they do
a couple throws a couple ratchet pulls
that night I'm in the render Farm
running Sims until the morning over and
over and over and over in the morning
the executives say we don't like it do
it again like look look look look at
this guy you see him no not the rock him
his stunt double you see that what does
he get he throws a few punches what does
he get he gets a truck The Rock gives
him a truck
what do I get
cropped out
where's my truck
if we can arrange a meeting between you
and a stunt man is that something that
you'd be open to
seriously sure
thanks for coming in I don't know if I
should be here it just doesn't seem like
a good idea to have me here this is the
movement is it good for you
hey man how's it going hey
Joel do you want to uh maybe say
anything
where do I start right
I mean maybe first question
when did you get your first truck
did Dwayne Johnson Drive it to you
himself
I wish not really didn't work like that
but you did get one yeah off Craigslist
um
yeah
I just don't know what to say to you
because I you know we did Black Panther
together we did
and I never talked to you I felt
overshadowed by you everyone was talking
about you know the Black Panther the guy
in the suit and that was you right but
then
I have to look at Chadwick Boseman and
he's black panther and then I'm just the
guy in the suit at the end of the day I
go to the movie and I don't see me I see
you and that was something I had to
struggle with right I had to to get over
the fact that wow I did this work and
now they have this Digi double replacing
me I realized there's Chadwick there's
me the stunt double and then there's you
the digi double like we're in this
together and of course we all want the
recognition I would love an Oscar a
nomination right won't we all for the
hard work that we do I mean they don't
do one for stunts I guess no no they
don't Expendable stunt man number five
right
huh
I always thought you were going to crazy
parties and hanging out with all the
celebrities bro I wasn't even invited to
the premiere how about that
you weren't no
I I was there but I had to buy a ticket
and I'm sorry I didn't talk to you on
set I'm honestly a little intimidated
bro like I'm a big fan of yours I was 11
years old and watching The Scorpion King
bro you killed it you were Scorpion and
King perfectly together it was so good
an amazing performance
so you know the Blood Sweat and Tears is
what makes what we do so impressive and
amazing right my tear ducts don't work
but right metaphorically I met four
o'clock right I put in my Blood Sweat
and Tears after you and it all forms a
beautiful bloody sweaty
pool of amazing yeah yeah you're amazing
man hmm
you're amazing too
thanks for this
you know I think I was wrong about ghee
he's actually a stand-up guy digi's and
Stoneman were were cut from the same
cloth did we do it for the wealth the
awards the accolades no no of course we
don't
we do it for the joy that we put on
those people's faces the smile on a kid
as they see it Tom Hanks pull up in
polar express and say All Aboard I mean
the reality is the work I do
it's gonna live on forever right the
haters the critics The Producers they're
they're human humans die like left and
right they're always dying but me
I'm Immortal
I'm immortal
in a thousand years I'll just be doing
my thing
and you'll be gone
when Digimon came out imagine how I felt
imagine what I I was thinking a digital
monster and uh technically I'm not a man
either legally no way I'm not a not a
man I I like to act like a person and oh
I'm at the store but I you know I I
thought I was going to get sucked into
something
okay